[Music]
another sneak peak of Sophia Richie's
debut on Keeping Up with the Kardashians
[Music]
and it gets a little awkward
Sofia join Scott Kourtney and their
kiddos in a hot tub in Finland and while
Kourtney helps Sophia fix some smudged
makeup Scott gets visibly uncomfortable
and that's when court kinda goes in on
Scott
kortnee that expresses her confusion
about why Scott is acting like this
Scott really wanted to come with us to
Finland
so I don't know why he's just having
such a negative attitude I just want
everyone to have a great time and a
great experience and he's just kind of
putting a dark cloud over it yeah but
this isn't the only time Scott gets
called out during this episode Sophia
also does it I want you to annasophia to
be comfortable you're sophisticated with
me and Kourtney's around it's also
important to note that Kourt is the one
who wanted Sophia to come I'm going to
Finland for spring break and I just said
to Scott like do you want to invite
Sophia they don't make me feel like I'm
left out though which is nice that's so
nice I wouldn't like don't go or invite
her to come the whole situation will
play out on Sunday but regardless of any
awkwardness we know Kourt and Scott are
committed Pope area I couldn't imagine
raising three children with somebody
that I couldn't speak to every day yeah
I do not get how people can do that I
think you just gotta figure out really
what's important to you at the end of
the day
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]